we have an update on a story we've been
following very closely it's about how
some vaping companies have been able to
avoid fda regulation even as they remain
popular among kids you'll recall we
recently sat down with two men who
present themselves anyway as top
executives at puffbar now the company
makes a range of vaping products
including sweet flavors and it's
important to point out
85 percent of teens who vape use
products with candy or fruit flavors the
fda has tried to crack down banning
flavored cartridges like jewel pods
early last year
but thanks to an apparent loophole
puffbar is still on the market
and now there are renewed questions
about why that's the case
nearly two years ago it seemed like the
federal government had put an end to
flavored vaping products the new policy
cracking down on the sale of flavored
electronic cigarettes but today what are
your top sellers in terms of flavors
probably cool mint yeah you know banana
ice blueberry blueberry ice nick minas
and patrick beltran are co-ceos of
puffbaar
the 27 year olds live a fast life on
social media
and they control the biggest company in
america still selling the kind of fruit
flavored nicotine products popular with
kids people always say like you guys are
trying to sidestep or sideskirt you know
kind of laws and we're not you know i
mean if there's a law that would order
us off the market tomorrow we would pull
our products off the market tomorrow in
fact the food and drug administration
has challenged puffbar before in a
warning letter last year it told the
company it did not have fda marketing
authorization required of all new
tobacco products but in february they
relaunch with what they say is a
tobacco-free nicotine that doesn't fall
under fda rules and so you're back with
essentially the same product
but the stuff inside
instead of tobacco nicotine is synthetic
nicotine yes
pretty clever
yeah i think it ended up being the
better alternative synthetic nicotine is
created through a chemical process that
does not involve tobacco leaves so the
argument is puffbar and any other
e-cigarette that follows this model is
no longer subject to the fda's rules for
tobacco products the fda has just been
slow and tentative and now they're
getting punked by two 27 year olds
illinois congressman raja krishnamoorthy
has been critical of pufbar since early
2020. when i go to their website and i
see strawberry banana
and raspberry ice and banana ice flavors
being sold i know exactly who they're
appealing to it's mainly kids beltran
and minas say their products are
intended exclusively for adult smokers
hoping to switch off cigarettes a market
they are so dedicated to serving they
argue they had to innovate these
loopholes have caused us to look for
alternative ways to still continue to
provide our consumers and customers with
the products that they need we see more
enjoyment with um our product now we
think there's definitely less by-product
compared to tobacco-derived nicotine
what do you mean by byproduct less
by-product less toxins less chemicals
i'm talking about
purely from an enjoyment standpoint of
how people are enjoying our products
it's cleaner bunk
total bunk that's not why they're doing
it dr robert jackler is a physician
turned tobacco researcher at stanford
would you call this a loophole that
companies are rushing through to stay on
the market it is an oklahoma land rush
going through a very wide loophole he
sees the turn to synthetic nicotine as
part of a decades-long effort by the
tobacco industry to evade regulations
every time the government brings in
regulations
the industry can innovate around it they
have the smartest people to think up
ways of skirting and undermining the
intent of regulation beltran and minas
both told us they think the fda's
worries are misplaced but you're not
saying hold on let's wait till the data
comes out you're just saying sorry fda i
see a way around you traditional
cigarettes on the market right now have
the fda stamp of approval
but those are not safe so why should the
u.s people or the people you know trust
the fda to be stamping approvals for the
safety of products when the fda
knowingly is allowing cigarettes to be
in the market
that are killing 480 000 people a year
the fda doesn't technically approve
tobacco products but it does determine
whether they meet legal requirements and
the agency hasn't yet taken a stand on
synthetic nicotine on its website the
fda admits it's possible synthetic
nicotine would not be regulated as a
tobacco product adding it plans to
decide on a case-by-case basis so is the
issue here the fda or puffbaar i think
it's both
congressman krishnamoorthy says he's
working on legislation to clarify the
government's role in regulating
synthetic nicotine i will make sure that
it's crystal clear in the law that they
should and can regulate in this area but
dr jackler says the fda's options are
already perfectly clear the fda has
authority
to take these products off the market if
they're not tobacco products and that's
what these companies assert then they're
a drug and they should be taken off
until approved why doesn't the fda do
that if it's so simple
that is the 10 billion dollar question
[Music]
and i wish you wish we could tell you we
had a good answer to that question we
once again reached out to the fda and it
once again declined an interview with us
saying that quote the fda is actively
investigating and considering how to
address such products the agency says it
looks forward to working with congress
on a potential fix the fda has by the
way pulled some 5 million e-cigarette
products off shelves in the past couple
years and every single one of them could
spring back through this synthetic
nicotine loophole
there's a statement said in sports
when it comes to teams trying to win if
you're not cheating you're not trying do
you believe this is simply the case like
they're finding these loopholes in these
ways around um in order to become rich i
think some companies are but what is
also important to point out is i've met
a lot of adults who have switched off
traditional cigarettes using an
e-cigarette often with flavor right and
so while there are irresponsible
companies in this space there are also
responsible ones and the fda has got to
sort one from another and help adults if
if that's the public health science
that's what it says right while keeping
it out of the hands of kids it's a tough
balance they've got to figure out
and there's still many questions you
know that phrase getting punked by a
couple of 27 year olds but then the
owners of puffbar made a good point
where they said the fda hasn't taken
cigarettes off the market that's true
absolutely
absolutely right
all right thank you tony